il a repoussé les limites de son sport
robert marchand 150 de guerre mondiale
et cesse président à son actif a établi
un nouveau record de l'heure dans une
catégorie d'âge créé spécialement pour
lui le centenaire a réalisé ce mercredi
4 janvier 22 km 547 m une performance
inédite pour le soutenir tout au long de
son défi une centaine de supporteurs de
son club de l'ardéchoise a fait le
déplacement
[Musique]
m partis le matin 6h30 on a passé une
journée formidable c'est donc mascotte
prochaine l'ardéchoise notre mascotte
supermarché c'est robert marchand du
père marchand c'est robert mans au total
plus de 80 journalistes et 1000
spectateurs ont garni les tribunes du
vélodrome
parmi eux marcel le quéré spécialistes
de la discipline qui pourrait s'attaquer
au record de robert marchand dans
quelques années j'ai encore 35 ans à
tenir pour arriver à son niveau c'est
exceptionnel ce qui fait déjà nous à 70
ans c'est déjà très difficile alors à
jonage
c'est merveilleux ça nous laisse de
l'espoir de tenir encore plusieurs
années
une journée parfaite pour robert
marchand mais le centenaire qui a tourné
à 35 secondes au tour à la fin de son
exploit ne se satisfait pas pleinement
de sa performance
j'ai pas vu l'air les 20 minutes
une simple erreur de jeunesse robert
marchand pourrait tenter de corriger ce
détail à l'occasion d'un nouveau record
dans deux ans
apparemment il lui en reste sous la
[Musique]